When we talk about
HTTPS, we are actually
talking about two
different concepts--
HTTP and TLS,
formerly known as SSL.
We already know about HTTP and
TLS stands or Transport Layer
Security.
TLS is not specific to HTTP,
but any protocol can use it.
For example, there
is FTPS, which
is FTP with TLS to
transfer files securely.
TLS encrypts
communication in a way
that can't be read by anyone
else other than the intended
recipients.
In practice, it is impossible
to break a TLS encryption.
To ensure that you're talking
to the server you intend
to talk to, TLS
utilizes something
called the chain of trust.
A server identifies
itself with a certificate
that contains both a little
metadata about itself
and the fingerprint
of an encryption key.
These certificates are issued by
one of a handful of certificate
authorities.
If that certificate is
signed by such an authority,
you know that if the key you are
using matches that fingerprint,
then you're talking
to the correct server.
The list of
certificate authorities
can actually be
found in the browser.
You could even add your very
own authority if you wanted to.
What you see here are
mostly companies that you
can buy certificates from.
They cost money as they not
only validate your server,
but also validate your identity
as the owner of that server.
Since not every
developer can or wants
to pay money for a
certificate to offer
basic security to the
users, Let's Encrypt
has come into the market and
offers certificates for free.
Let's take a closer look
at how certificates work
and the security they provide.